[Music]
Call of Duty's wall zone is here to give
us yet another option in the Battle
Royale space it's still all fresh and
new and as we learn more we'll make an
updated list but right now here's 100
things that will give you the edge and
hopefully net you a decent amount of
wins if you have a tip please throw it
in the comments below and our height
your comment to get you noticed 100 tips
and tricks to survive and win in the war
zone let's go
when jumping out of the plane note
something important your parachute will
automatically deploy at a respectable
level all by itself hurrah
you can also cut those ropes to cancel
any chutes but remember the second chute
will not auto deploy you will go splat
quite funny to see when a teammate does
it do you know that holding the left
shoulder button on console gives you a
third-person view when parachuting into
the map it's easier to maneuver and it's
absolutely great for surveying the area
too you can keep an eye out for other
teams and see where they're all landing
so how do you get far and land fast it's
pretty simple drop face-first and once
you hit a high enough speed pull your
chute this will give you a boost in a
lateral movement about four times
quicker than just sticking with the
chute then cut the chute and repeat to
go far and fast many people I played
with over the last four days didn't
realize we always have a parachute
available so if you find yourself on a
rooftop jump off don't look for the
stairs to get down run and jump like a
madman the holy grail of parachuting is
taking somebody out before you even land
and of course Jack's already donates if
it's been a while since you last played
a Call of Duty title he is a great thing
to note
aiming down sights when walking through
a door lets you peek through this makes
less noise keeps you covered and
stealthy too of course everybody else
just runs straight through doors and
smashes them open instantly but like
this you can be a stealthy genius
another mechanic in this BR unlike
fortnight is the ability to mount
weapons to objects to reduce the recoil
in general it's useful especially salt
with LMGs here's one I just realized is
here wall banging yep in warzone we can
shoot through walls not all of them mind
it's usually just wood but not trees
those things are made of titanium when a
match begins notice how much help and
armor you have it's tons you can go
straight into battle if you're a legend
with the starting pistol use it to your
advantage
and rack up early kills and hey you can
run away and win fights later if you
have to the time to kill is pretty long
with a starting pistol especially at
medium range you have time to change
your plans
so you'll likely be killed in the game
at some point and venture into the Gulag
if you're completely new this is the
place where you have a second chance to
get back in the game by defeating an
opponent in a one-on-one fight this is
only available once to you and always
before the fifth circle of the storm
or should I say gasps anyway after that
there are no second chances if you find
yourself here tactics go out the window
completely but there are still two
abilities which are regularly ignored
holding Crouch slide around the corner
or the good old Call of Duty jump shot
man that jump shot hits me so many times
the theory is pretty simple we all aim
around head height in these tight
one-on-ones so sliding or jumping will
force your foe to miss that first shots
forcing them to adjust their aim giving
you the opening you need to win the
battle if you own the retail version of
modern warfare the best thing you can do
is jump into gunfights or the one-on-one
mode this will hone your reactions and
allow you to more accurately predict to
what a standard player will do in the
Gulag whilst we're here I'm sure you've
noticed you can throw rocks well the
ability to put off other competitors is
cool but those rocks can actually
trigger items like c4
it won't happen very often but you can
impact the fight and yes it's even
possible to claim another elimination
should you die at the same time as a
teammate you may be in a gulag at the
same time if you're observing your
friend give them call-outs to help in
the fight keep them short and simple we
call the areas back mid and home spawn
and left right and center a simple quick
and concise call should give them the
other hand and they should win their
battle and even if you lose yours
there's a chance they can bring you back
teamwork makes the dream work so I'm
told
half the people will be unlucky in here
they will die in the gulag but please
don't leave that's what people do wait
for your team to raise $4,500 to buy
your life back again here's the key tip
ignored often pool your cash by holding
down on the d-pad players can drop the
cash to a teammate to raise the funds
quicker and yeah drop other stuff to
keep the squad in tip-top shape to buy
back a player visit the stars which use
shopping cart icons by the way in the UK
we call these trolleys the team
redeploys are on the right just in case
you have tunnel vision from carrying all
your team mates while we're at the store
if you're unable to find armor in the
world just get it bought it's cheap and
will save your life
prioritize it even above a self revive
stay alive rather than walk the
tightrope of death another great item to
buy is a drone like you'd expect
it's a flying camera I recommend holding
up inside a house or building before
flying this guy around surveying the
entire area for teammates completely
risk-free alternatively grab the UAV
yeah I know you know about the red dots
on the mini-map but you're missing
something truly brilliant click on the
map screen and you'll see just how far
your UAV spans it's ridiculous it gives
you such an edge in decision-making and
attacking enemy squads of course all
this stuff costs money which is found
all around the open world and those
Intel opportunities too don't be fooled
that they are grayed out on the mini-map
they are still active and you can get
your hands on them scavenger and recon
contracts are quick and easy to raise
funds but if the bounties which are a
huge tip here and not for the reason
you're expecting upon picking up a
bounty you can tell where another team
is yeah you can run to them and start a
fight immediately or if you're more
passive simply knowing another team's
location for even a few minutes is
completely worth picking it up at the
moment was only set to trio's and they
know I don't have to say this but I'm
gonna do it anyway
just like in apex legends stick is a
squad to make the game far easier we all
love a good old solo bloodbath but to
quote myself teamwork makes the dream
work how many times have I said that
today before we move on from the buy
stations here's something which will
become so much more prominent the longer
the game is out other teams will camp
with the respawn stations in the hopes
of easy kills sweep the area before
paying for teammates too rich
another quick super tip wall zone is
another BR with a great pinging system
use it to communicate when off-mic
simply up on the d-pad if you missed it
want to notify others two taps to signal
danger okay yeah I come clean 100 tips
is a very difficult number to reach I
needed things like this just like an
apex we can tag weapons and by tagging
back we can claim the weapon for
ourselves to keep it on the hood until
it's picked up oh and the little circles
next to your ping indicate who in your
team agrees with the plan here two of us
agreed to meet at the dam let's quickly
go over the rarities in war zone just
like in fortnight and apex we have a
color scheme to let us know the loot
rarity but here's the thing to remember
grey weapons are just as great as the
others Grail weapons are great if you
use them correctly the key difference
though are the mods on the weapons green
blue purple and the good old godly gold
orange are the ones you've seen in other
BRS gold here though are the highest
weapon tiers to be found that I usually
fully modded and that is indicated by
these dots modifications are a huge deal
in Call of Duty but in warzone they are
not switchable we can't change them they
are permanent which leads me to my next
point perfectly did you know that
warzone is pay to wind yes totally is
sadly it's true but it's possible to use
it to your advantage to free-to-play
players Cod uses an XP system which
unlocks attachments and other weapons so
in your own retail version of Call of
Duty you are able to level up in all the
modes you play to build your perfect
loadout to get your hands on that in
warzone look out for these loadout drops
if you have the perfect AR all balanced
how you want it to be this is your first
real opportunity to get your hands on it
if you want to sniper rifle that
actually kills people instead of tickles
them set it up before venturing into the
war zone and don't worry if you only
want one weapon from y'all saved loadout
select it and your current weapons will
instantly fall to the ground
simply sift through what you want take
the best of both worlds if only one
person on your squad has the retail
version of modern warfare here's a
little cheat to the system have that
player create you a loadout in their
game then when they open the loadout
drop they can select your loadout
on the ground but sadly they won't be
able to claim another one for themselves
so here's a tip maybe have one loadout
with both of your favorite weapons in
and share the spoils the time spent
faffing around here might get you killed
but free-to-play players can circumvent
the system a little which I thought was
pretty cool and on the other side of
that if your entire squad is playing the
free version of warzone
well definitely it will be a harder time
but we can do this it's simple camp out
at the loadout drops you know that the
core owners of the game want their gear
so let them select it and the moment
they have it murder them all and take
what they grinded hours to accomplish
survival of the fittest I'm told
regardless of if you have the full game
or not keep an eye on all the pink
custom loot which drops there could be
something you've never encountered
before including the exclusive ps4
weapons and as this game-mode is
cross-platform you'll get to try them on
PC and Xbox here's a strange one I've
noticed from my first four days playing
the game nobody at all uses throwables
grenades c4 mines nobody uses them so
switch that around and use yours to kill
your opponent and then pick theirs up
afterwards because they want to use
theirs either the skins we choose our
arguably pay to win - if you have that
option if you're planning to be a sniper
in the Hills choose the ghillie suit if
you plan to be in the shadows go as dark
as possible and if you spend most of
your time in the snow dress accordingly
speaking of play style the grenades and
other throwables you decide to take with
you impact that taking a proximity mind
to block the front door of a house
you're holed up in is always a smart
move and I also recommend smoke grenades
if you play as a sniper to allow you to
relocate without running in the open
different tactics of different loadouts
moving back to those with the full
version of call of duty modern warfare
there are other pay2win measures you can
take advantage of in pregame lobbies you
are able to gain XP by simply using the
weapons on other people this is useful
if you get a long Lobby which will
happen at some point you're randomly
given a weapon and you may unlock
something for it without really even
trying when creating a custom loadout
think about adding a thermal scope or an
infrared scope this will make target
acquisition unbelievably easier but to
turn this on its head all the
attachments you use
impact the weapon in both positive and
negative ways making characters run
slower if you've used an extended mag or
increasing reload times and weapon
swapping speeds there's a lot more under
the hood than you may think
but if you want to go quick choose
lightweight weapons here's a basic
example of a pistol versus a heavier
weapon just over a few steps the
difference in speed is staggering let's
go over to vehicles vehicles killed duh
but they won't kill our teammates
thankfully a good use for a vehicle is
to offer cover when crossing something
wide open like the airfield but keep in
mind they are not bulletproof your head
is exposed most of the time chopper
pilots they always seem to think they're
bulletproof something to note about the
quad it's for two people right well you
can fit an entire team on this dream
work makes the team work : whatever the
saying was and what about camping in
this game yes I know it's everyone's
favorite topic and yes it most
definitely is a key skill in warzone
without a doubt is the easiest way to
get a win if that's your desired result
commandeering an entire building holding
the high ground and staying silent to
ambush another team is a great tactic if
I'm honest though I don't recommend
playing passive unless it's the right
situation and get yourself involved in
the action it's far more fun aggressive
but not stupid is a good motto - go buy
a few items which are integral on your
journey should you be lucky enough to
find them are the gas masks oh these are
pure gold the gas outside of the safety
zone is completely deadly way more than
in any other BR before it having a mask
on hand will let you survive a few extra
seconds it's a godsend it really is if
you're playing solo
I recommend the heartbeat sensor to
identify the location of all members of
a closeby team the amount of times I've
used this personally to secure a hot
spot and revive my friends is countless
it's a rare find but it's so fun to use
all going back to pay2win dolls with the
full game you are able to pick your
perks for this game - so for example
select scavenger to instantly replenish
ammo from dead players and the ghost
perk is a must-have as it makes you
undetectable by UAVs radar drones and
even the heartbeat sensor
damn that's good to pay2win sadly but it
is here
okay we're near the end now a few
PlayStation centric things to note if
you have PS plus even though warzone
doesn't need it you can claim a bunch of
extras from skins watches and even my
guitar as a weapon chomp I like that
it's nice isn't it's nice if you're
having trouble running the game on ps4
and experience stutter a quick fix is to
change your ps4 theme to something
static this will also speed up the UI
and make everything a little more fluid
that's 98 I need two more always
remember you can practice with bots
whenever you feel like it and see if
those new weapon variations suit you and
okay the boss a terrible saucer bug tips
so let's change that one too
you can farm BOTS in the practice mode
to gain XP for your gear nice how do I
get to number 100 oh I know parachuting
into water is an instant death happy
days so there we have it a newbie are on
the block and guess what everyone is a
newb right now so get in there and get
ahead of the curve before you are a lamb
to the slaughter this definite perks to
owning the full game but a good player
can definitely take advantage of those
pay to win mechanics to get the dub in
the future the player limit will be
growing to 200 which will make the game
even less likely to win but such a rush
if you achieve it if you have any tips
please throw them in the comments below
I'll make a follow-up video and name all
the sexy people that helped right I'm
going back into warzone I am Adam from
Playstation grenade hopefully this has
helped in some way it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]